Hey look guys my name is China welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we took a look at an introduction
to rendering definitely check that video
out if you haven't already because today
we're going to continue off kind of
where we left off in that video and
actually talk about the architecture of
this whole renderer and just the whole
problem of we need to render graphics on
the screen how do we do that in an
engine as promised I did prepare a
little bit of a PowerPoint presentation
which should be pretty cool so going to
jump in that into that in just a second
but I just want to kind of start off by
just saying first of all huge thank you
to all the patrons that make this series
possible patreon come forth out of the
gener
thank your support just means the world
to me especially right now because I'm
so busy and I still want to be able to
pump out these videos for you guys and
just seeing that people are so
interested in support of this series is
absolutely amazing to me if you're
interested in becoming a patron
definitely check out that link you'll
receive a bunch of rewards such as
videos early although that's kind of on
hold at the moment since my life so
crazy but you'll get access to things
like source code for hazel engine that
has already been like whale away written
in in advance essentially so this kind
of stuff that we're covering now has
somewhat been implemented already and
it's all usable in a branch and just
kind of as like as a way to kind of get
more of like I guess more control into
where hazel actually going being and
being able to steer it into the right
direction i commonly post things on
discord as well and the kind of patrons
channel relating to Hazel's development
as i write the code and like it's almost
like a development blog at times i try
and do that just to keep you guys
updated with what I'm actually working
on because obviously I work on hazel
kind of independently and then
eventually what I kind of implement
eventually we're way later in the future
makes its way to videos such as this one
and also obviously in these videos I
explain what I'm doing a lot more and
talk about like how we're going to
structure certain things anyway
rendering architecture let's dive in
okay sir rendering architecture in the
hazel engine first of all that beautiful
background is not rendered in hazel
that's actually a photo I took and
pretty much the South of Victoria here
in Australia if you want to see more of
my photos
in ceramic on floor / the channel will
be a link in description because I do
love photography as well but maybe one
day we can render something like this in
hazel that would be quite nice quite a
good goal to aim for anyway there are
two sides to this whole thing and I
guess one of the things that I should
probably talk about I mean in the
introduction to rendering video I did
cover a lot and I don't want to really
overlap too much so we're going to
taking more of a practical approach at
this now but effectively the way that I
kind of see this is there are two sides
to a rendering system in a game engine
there's something called the render API
which again these turn is that this
terminology is something that I've
essentially made up I mean it does make
sense obviously and other people have
used it in the past and do use it but
this isn't like from some text book or
anything like that so don't expect that
but essentially what we have is a render
API which is the platform and API render
API graphics API specific part of this
whole system that we're building what
that means is that this is actually
specific to OpenGL specific to Vulcan
specific to DirectX this is this kind of
this side of this line is stuff that we
actually tie in to those platforms or
those api's whereas this side which
we'll get into you know which we'll get
into kind of in the future once we get
through all the all of these points this
is going to be like the render kind of
the API platform independent kind of
side of this side of these two two sides
side of these two sides of the system so
let's take a look at what we've got so
random on text right so again this side
what this is is it's an implementation
that is implemented like in OpenGL or in
Vulcan or there is actual API so this is
the stuff that is specific that we have
to basically implement per API there's
no way around that right so we have
essentially what do we build right so we
build a render context we build things
like a swap chain a frame buffer vertex
buffer might just be easier till just
list all these I think at once an index
buffer you know texture kind of API
shared or API States pipelines render
passes and then we'll kind of move on to
the next side so let's talk about this
for a bit what I mean by this is that
these are essentially
in a way I guess you could call them
render API primitives and I probably
missed like a bunch of things this is
just like a loose kind of off the top of
my head kind of list but essentially we
need to if we're if we're like and the
way that we're gonna start this out is
you'll see in the next slide is by
implementing OpenGL so if we use that as
an example right what we need to do is
essentially make you could say a class
for each of these things but essentially
an implementation for OpenGL for like
this render context the swap chains
frame buffer the vertex buffer index
buffer because these are kind of render
primitives out of which we tell our
graphics card what it is we want to do
right so things like a vertex buffer
right we have a buffer of data we want
to send it into the GPU and then
actually be able to use it maybe like
kono statically maybe dynamically
however we want to use that right we
need an API to be able to do that and
the cool thing about this is that we
implement this in every API so in other
words we'd have an implementation for
OpenGL we would have an implementation
for Falcon right and then once we have
that we can actually use it from the
renderer side of things agnostic Lee
right which means that it doesn't matter
we have one implementation of the
renderer which just says okay first up
create a render context in a swap chain
then you know create any frame buffers
you might need for actual rendering then
I want to render a triangle so let's
upload some vertex buffer data and some
index buffer data and we're going to
create a shader of course and then we'll
like create a render pass or a pipeline
or anything else we need
and then we'll kick off rendering that
triangle right that's it okay but the
thing is to render a triangle we use
this render api from the renderer and
the cool thing about this is that
suddenly if we decide well actually less
render using Vulcan or DirectX 12 or
whatever this part obviously is the part
that contains the actual implementation
of those api's but this part does not
change we just have to hit a switch that
says okay now do it in direct x12
but our logic for drawing a triangle our
actual run the commands that we
are essentially going to be the same now
in the last video in the introduction to
rendering video I talked about how it
was really hard to kind of draw the line
and this is the line this is the line I
was talking about I've drawn that line
and I've said this is on this side this
is on this side all right but now you
actually kind of see what actually
belongs to each kind of side again if I
want to suddenly add a texture to a
triangle right what do I do I just say
ok let's load a texture and bind it and
we'll draw using that texture right and
we'll update the shader code obviously
to actually sample from that texture and
then draw those pixels but how do we use
that texture we just say all we want to
make a texture right the implementation
details of ok what does it even mean I
want to make a texture you know am I
going to read that from a file and then
what I'm gonna do with that data right
is that going to be implemented by by
DirectX 12 or Vulcan or OpenGL or
whatever that is on this side of the
line
right so this is just an API that
provides us access to that kind of lower
level code but then we use this API in
our renderer to actually render what we
want okay and the benefit of that
obviously is that um it doesn't matter
what API we under the hood it's kind of
like we're creating another API on top
of all those other api's it's going to
do exactly what we want in a much much
much simpler way usually and then all
the hard work is kind of done behind the
scenes right that's kind of the whole
idea so let's take a look at things that
the renderer would be responsible for so
the actual 2d and 3d render alright
weather weather that before were
deferred whatever that is going to be
implemented largely using actual kind of
parameters from this now I have to
mention that there are differences in
the API like I didn't just say last
episode that all this is gonna be so
hard it's always so hard to do this and
then here I'm like that's easy we know
inter-school live so I'm gonna list all
these dot points we're gonna do this and
that everything's gonna be sweet no
because you know implementing a deferred
renderer in OpenGL versus something like
Vulcan it's different because in Vulcan
you just have kind of more of these
primitives than you do in OpenGL in
OpenGL you just kind of create like a
bunch of frame buffers and that's kind
of it whereas in Vulcan you know you can
have like things like pipelines and like
descriptive sets and
just more kind of just more actual
content for this which is why something
like open like I I can't OpenGL or
something completely different
- like Vulcan or directx12 because it is
right like the approach to some of these
advanced rendering techniques is
actually quite different so it's gonna
be interesting when we get into things
like deferred rendering or even like
tile based rendering or anything like
that right because the way that we kind
of set this up might actually differ and
we might have to purple might have to
extend this render api and basically you
know whenever we need to just write more
vulcan courage than otherwise possible
with these primitives because we want a
more efficient way of deferred rendering
for example because you can't achieve
deferred rendering with these primitives
that's fine but Vulcan might have a
better way of doing it by using like
more control essentially and obviously
Vulcan has things like that you know
seeing the synchronization parameters
like fences and semaphores and that kind
of stuff right not something that
Penelope has so there's gonna be some
difference it's not gonna be as
straightforward as this might look cuz I
don't want you guys to think that I've
I've made it out to be so hard in the
last episode and then suddenly I'm just
like that it's gonna be easy it's not
gonna be easy I'm just simplifying it
for you guys so that we can actually
start doing this and so that you don't
feel too overwhelmed but maybe feel a
little bit overwhelmed just cuz I don't
want to like make this have to be
actually more simple than it is so
because of that yeah like we might have
to say well you know what it doesn't
make sense to have a deferred renderer
implemented with just these like
platform and API agnostic primitives
that might not make any sense and that's
totally fine because then what we'll do
is we'll move that part of the code into
the render API zone now the downside the
draw but that usually what happens when
you make that decision is things get
more efficient but you suddenly have
more code because suddenly anything you
move obviously into the render api zone
needs to be implemented per api so we
need to suddenly have a deferred
rendering or whatever implementation for
opengl for Valken from whatever api is
we actually choose to support which we
kind of want to avoid obviously what we
actually want to do is try and have as
much code as possible in that
platform and API agnostic kind of
section of our code because that means
that we don't have to have a separate
event implementation every time we want
to do that the reason we have this line
in general this might seem like a silly
question but I know some people might be
a little bit confused the reason why we
have this line is because again think
back to rendering a triangle do we want
to write code four or five times per API
if we have like DirectX 12 if we have
Vulcan if we have OpenGL if we have
metal whatever do we want to write code
to render a triangle for each API no
what we want to do is create all these
primitives and then as I kind of
described you know will create a vertex
before anything that's before the
texture you know the shader whatever we
need we create that and then like the
code to draw a triangle is just easily
handled by hazel right and then that
kind of branches off into all those API
so that we really only need to write
that code once we want to render a
triangle this is the correct render
triangle we write it once and then it
kind of you know will eventually lower
lower and low level as it kind of goes
down into the API it will eventually hit
you know whatever render API we're using
such as OpenGL or direct x12 anyway
let's get back into this render thing so
things like a same graph right like a
same manager that's not something you
usually have in you know you don't want
to write raw opengl code kind of in that
like for that kind of system it's
something that is you know it doesn't
have anything to do with actual
rendering API is you know you have like
sorting right deciding what to render
when right some things might need to be
rendered after certain other things
because of things like blending but also
we typically want to be able to sort
things that use the same material or the
same shader or the same texture kind of
together so that we don't need to switch
States
I've often things like culling right so
what fits into our frosting maybe some
kind of occlusion culling as well those
systems again have nothing to do with
specific render api's left to do them
for every single round or api so why not
just have like why don't why does why
not just have the render
and a lot right materials so materials
are very closely tied with shaders
essentially what a material is is just a
shader plus some uniform data I meant
from there we'll probably have things
like material instances which are based
on materials that's typically how most
renderers and most engines kind of work
but again that's something that is
implemented here so having like
client-side uniform storage and then a
shader linked and all that stuff that's
that that we that applies to every
single render API that's not different
whereas something like a texture or a
vertex buffer you know might be
different to render API which is why we
need it to be here and not here right
hopefully this is making sense
lots of right level of detail so meshes
that we have lower quality and like kind
of smaller meshes essentially in terms
of polygon count and triangle count and
the further away we decide to render
something so that we don't render as
many triangles systems like that not
something that belongs in the actual
render API animation as well it's purely
kind of a client-side renderer
implementation of that doesn't need any
actual render API support cameras right
again something that is just you know we
need to like maybe a camera might be
tied to a frame buffer maybe a camera
might be rendering to a render target
right that kind of stuff implemented on
the renderer side doesn't need to be
part of that I'm in fact render passes
almost belong here as well the reason I
put it put them here is because they can
be seen as a primitive and they are
implemented differently in different
render api's but in general you know if
we want to control like if we want a big
you know and a render pass again
there'll be an API for that in the
actual renderer as well on visual
effects so things like particle systems
that stuff as well is now that stuff may
these stuff don't get me wrong will
require support from render api things i
didn't list here are things like you
know batching for example or instancing
right batching is something something
that you usually can be controlled by
the render side whereas instancing
requires render api support so things
like that suddenly you decide you want
to bash something but you want to use
instancing in this case that requires
instancing to be kind of set up in the
api here but then can be used from the
renderer so that's
as well post-effects and by that I mean
specifically a post-effects system right
so actually if you break down what
postfix is you know we render our scene
to a frame buffer and then we use a
different shader to just render you know
a quarter on the screen using a vertex
buffer with kind of outpost effects
applied here but also you know for post
effects is common that we might need
additional data that we wouldn't need
immediately so for example very simple
post effects might be something like a
color correction that's easy because
what do we do we render our scene to a
frame buffer and then we render we
render that frame buffer again using a
different shader onto another quad and
then display that on our screen and then
that shader might do the color
correction whereas if we want to do
something like screen space ambient
occlusion right not a great effect but
let's just go with it we need some other
data for Mallory from our original
render pass such as like position or
normal data right we want those normals
into like a separate buffer so we can
then read them in our post effects
shader because we need that we need that
in way we need that extra information
that we didn't need before we ran that
post effect so things like that right so
it's kind of it does tie in together a
specifically I do mean it's post effects
system the way that it might handle
those render passes and there's
additional data that we need is
something that typically would be
implemented by the renderer
because this renderer just uses this API
that we've created just so that it
doesn't need to use OpenGL specifically
or any actual Ram for API specifically I
hope you guys know which render rapier
I'm talking about when I just say render
API sometimes I'm talking about this
list sometimes I'm talking about OpenGL
welcome that kind of thing but hopefully
it makes sense um other things so I
think you know like I guess render
techniques like reflections I mean
occlusion you know setting up
reflections in terms of like reflection
probes you know rendering to like cube
maps doing things like ambient occlusion
whether that being a first post effects
or like kind of more advanced you know
hpi-o or whatever other other kind of
render techniques we have available to
us those things are typically
implemented you know in the renderer
that's something that we do there
because we don't
like sometimes we might need extra API
support but if you think about it
usually we should be able to get this
API pretty strong to the point where we
don't need to suddenly implement like
finer grained things inside the actual
rendering yeah every time we want to do
like a different technique right now I
do want to say though that the reason
this has become difficult is because as
nice as this might seem like we can just
have a render API right that seems great
like we have a renter API we make it
really strong it handles everything
suddenly every time I want to do
anything in my renderer I have to write
it once and I'll just work on every
render API we support
that's a great dream to have but in
practice that's usually not a very
optimized way of doing things the reason
is that if you try and make a generalist
render API you have the same problems as
if you try and make a generalist game
engine right it's a game engine that can
be used for any game in the water
anything you can think of you can make
with this game engine but is that going
to be better than if I have if I write
my own specific engine for my specific
game nore it's not gonna be better which
is where the starts become dangerous
because ideally speaking like if you get
into advanced techniques that actually
do require more performance are you
going to be able to write a generalist
API and use that and receive the same
level of performance and just
optimization as you are if you just use
raw DirectX 12 directly of course not
right so you have to really be careful
with this and we'll kind of as we go
along we'll kind of run into stuff like
this and have probably some serious
discussions and may even like implement
things one way and then be like well
actually this isn't as good as like this
other tests I did over the weekend and
it turned out to be better and we might
go back on that and I don't know
generally should be pretty fun but I'm
just kind of warning you guys of some
potential problems that will inevitably
arise from stuff like this okay so with
that in mind one of the things that I
didn't mention which we will also have
to pretty much design is essentially a
like a render command Q all right and
this kind of ties in like between the
renderer telling the render AP
what to do right and I ran to command Q
is just basically a way for us to encode
every single render command into like a
bigger buffer so that once per frame
when we actually decide to like render
everything essentially we go through
that command queue and we execute all
those commands and typically the data is
all in line we can run it on diff on a
different thread if we want to unlike a
dedicated render thread so that while
it's kind of going through that render
queue we could be doing other stuff like
submitting more render commands for the
next frame or doing game logic or doing
AI or anything else on our kind of main
thread so that's a render command Q you
know an API like Vulcan has command
queues right that's what you do in
Vulcan you kind of you have a bunch of
commands like for example you know bind
this and then draw this triangle and
then you know this is what my this is my
scissors State this is my people at
state and what you do is you put all of
that into a like into a queue
essentially and then eventually you tell
Vulcan I want it I want you to actually
present that cue right when you actually
go through that queue and then do that
rendering thing so Vulcan has that but
like OpenGL doesn't so we need to create
that for up in jail and you know just in
general if you have like a choice of
like okay I want to implement three
api's what do I make them like usually
the choices I'll make them like DirectX
right because Dredd text like familiy
seems to be the most sensible actual API
right so we might follow that kind of
design but because I like making new
things and cuz hazel is a new project
for me I might just try and make my own
thing and we'll see what happens and
that's why that's where we as a
community we're going to work together
and we try and build something new or
something cool so just giving you guys a
little bit of insight there so where do
we start talking is great but we need to
actually start this thing so how are we
gonna do that well first of all we're
gonna start with up in jail now would i
start with opengl if I was just making
my own engine like full-on without
making a video series out of it probably
not probably wouldn't support OpenGL at
all to be honest just start with like
Vulcan maybe but the problem is OpenGL
is the simplest and the easiest API
requires a bit of a stronger design from
outside to make it actually good but
it's the simplest and easiest thing
right we want that because this is a
game engine series it's not necessarily
a graphics series I am obviously heavily
interested in graphics and I love
graphics since my favorite part of this
whole thing to be honest but I do
recognize this as a game engine we have
kind of two goals first of all we want
to see stuff on the screen as soon as
possible and see beautiful things on the
screen as soon as possible because
that's gonna be great to actually see
results and obviously a lot of you guys
actually want results because this is a
youtube series and it has to be fun in
that case and it has to be marketable
from my point of view as well I have to
be able to make pretty thumbnails with
like hey look hey zhalandin looks great
even though you know if I try something
like Vulcan the architecture might be
amazing we might have done a lot of code
work but do we have anything pretty -
sure
not really so there's that side and the
other side is we don't want to spend two
years implementing rendering api's we
want to get something up and running and
then move on to something else like a
scene like a scene system or like a
level editor like tool set or like
sterilization and like data like that or
actual logic and scripting or like an
empty component system we have so many
other systems we need to deal with so
using our congeal is not ideal but you
will get the job done right not in the
best way possible not in the fastest way
possible but it will get the job done
so I'll step one with that is to build
that render API part so when I talked
about this and all of these things
that's what we begin with we build that
stuff once we've done that we build the
other side which is the renderer of
course these do have overlap they're not
dependent on each other right so for
example we don't need the render API to
be complete before we can begin the
renderer once we have enough in the
render API to like draw a triangle
guess what we're gonna do we're gonna
write a renderer that can draw a
triangle okay so that we get that stuff
up and running and then we'll iterate
over it and we'll add more things as we
need them you know suddenly we want to
be able to render to a texture or
something like that we'll add the frame
buffer in the texture target texture
render talk an API at that point okay
after that we have a base to render
anything we want right and of course by
build renderer I am talking about things
like we need to build a material system
maybe like a shader Plaza stuff like
that that'll be kind of included in step
two essentially but after that we can
render anything we want
you know we want to render lie
it's cool like PBR materials and like 3d
models and all that my stuff we can we
should be able to so once we can do that
once in OpenGL I can render like a full
3d scene that looks beautiful right
we've probably post effects and all of
that stuff that's when we're going to
implement other api's now this is and I
did write to be decided because as I
said we probably want to do things like
a scene you know scene level edited
civilization all that other stuff I
mention in the important system
scripting all that stuff we probably
want to do before we start diving into
other api's but this is a serious for
you guys if you guys decide that you
know we've got enough stuff let's just
implement bulk and I really want to
learn about that if the majority of
people decide that now I'm gonna do that
right I would love to do that to be
honest but I'm just thinking about what
the majority of people want and
obviously trying to make this series
something that you guys enjoy and
something that like especially like the
patrons actually want to see but not
just patrons don't think that I'm just I
only care about people who support me
financially obviously I care about all
of my viewers but um of course one of
the perks of supporting me I guess is
that you get to steer this series a
little bit more into where you actually
want but yeah so welcome to our text
eleven and twelve metal that kind of
stuff that I will get to that eventually
but this is kind of the stuff I want
first right we're gonna start with the
simplest API possible and we're gonna
make we're gonna make something that
looks pretty and then after we have that
we can move on to other stuff if we kind
of have the time and resources to do
something like that okay so that's
pretty much it thanks for watching guys
hope in your this video if you do do hit
that like button you can also help
sponsors on patreon as I've mentioned
throughout this video I do want to say
that like this is a big journey this is
something that's going to take us awhile
OpenGL is very verse is very simple in a
lot of cases it's also because it's so
simple it can also be annoying in a lot
of cases but I think we're gonna have a
generally easy time with that so I'm not
too worried about the actual details
about like about that kind of stuff we
should get something up and running
pretty quickly I would think this is a
good opportunity to take to check out my
OpenGL series if you haven't already
there's a playlist of like 20 I think
also videos that will kind of cover a
lot of these primitives I don't think
I've got an idea
I didn't get into like advance things
like frame buffers um not that's
particularly advanced but I didn't get
to things like that
I didn't think or you know ready targets
or just like a lot of that kind of stuff
I probably will eventually in that
series I think what I'll do is I'll
short an implementation of like hey you
know we need to write a frame buffer
class in hazel let's just do that but
then I'll link to an OpenGL stories
video that I'll make about frame buffers
where it actually talks about how frame
buffers work in OpenGL so I'll probably
be I'll probably resume the open video
series a lot as the kind of move
throughout this now next weekend which
is usually what I make videos is my
bachelor party because as I mentioned in
previous video I'm getting married in
less than a month now
so because of that I'm not gonna be able
to make a video next weekend I hope you
guys understand I mean if you know kind
of balanced my life in this full-time
job and all the stuff's going on it's
just my head's exploding so this is
again as I mentioned a good time to go
back and watch that OpenGL series and
maybe even try and implement a renderer
yourself right try to in front those
things that I've outlined in in the
design and then with that API that
you've created this OpenGL specific or
rather platform-agnostic kind of try and
then use that API to actually draw a
triangle that's a really good place to
start
of course you can you will be able to
draw a triangle if you watch that opengl
series so that's kind of my homework and
my like what I want you guys to do while
I kind of have this have is break next
week and then we'll just get back into
it and to be honest I'm really looking
forward to it so hope you guys enjoy
this video and I'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]